[Applause]
producer extraordinaire Norman Lear my
next guest as the hilarious seen Stiller
from the Mindy project her new Netflix
special sweet-and-salty is out right now
take a look my entire family loved
eating at Hooters even my mom liked
eating at Hooters because you could buy
a wheelbarrow of wings for four dollars
she's like everybody's rich at Hooters
however she wasn't always willing to
admit that she liked hooters I've been
the hooters my entire life not with me I
have never been to Hooters I'm like you
recruited my babysitter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god you're so funny
thank you oh my god I love you meet
Norman Lear he was I'm so strong he was
cracking up her butt crack not watching
you here Hooters spill I love it I'm
between two legends no not the same
[Applause]
your accent reminds me of home I always
live it I run into you why it just feels
so where did you grow up I grew up in
North Carolina my mom made me be a
debutante that's how slow you're a
southern belle you're a southern belle
wait what did that entail what did you
have to do oh my gosh you are so fancy
right now yo I had to wear white oh my
god
you were from like the bricks I was from
the sticks girl we didn't have anything
like that soon yeah but we had no money
I that was the thing my mom had been one
and then we lost all our money you know
gambling then she still wanted me to
carry on this tradition of being uh
pretending to be rich and then go to
anacott classes I don't have my face
with a napkin and you know you can't
wipe your face like a monster obviously
I didn't attend etiquette I still to
this day people are like you should
never eat in public I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this